this is the moment a sporting superstar
was born
sealed with an ace the most joyously
unexpected story in british sporting
history
and this is what it means for 18 year
old emma radekanu and her team
they arrived in new york just hoping to
qualify for this tournament now she's
the first british woman to win a grand
slam title in 44 years and leaving 1.8
million pounds richer
how are you feeling emma has it sunk in
yet no not at all i mean
i've barely had a moment to really sink
in and enjoy and embrace i know your
parents not out here but have you had a
chance to speak to them to hear how
they're feeling about what you've
achieved yeah i've had a conversation
um not on my phone i haven't checked
that yet but
they were they were extremely happy and
proud of me and you know they're my
toughest and biggest critics
three months ago emirata khanu was
virtually unknown outside tennis circles
she's now one of the most famous faces
in sport
travel restrictions meant only a few
home fans were lucky enough to witness
history in person a lot of the brits who
would normally come over we can't get
here so we thought we'd fly up from
miami for the day and just support her
you know we just think she's amazing i
think that the way she played her
control her
how she was able to focus on one point
at a time who knows how far she can go
her name up in lights and likely to be
so for many years to come even emma
adakanu can't believe that this is real
martha kellner sky news new york